607 the 20th celebration of the world
tea conference and expo is in town
it's a big deal there's a lot of words
in that in that name of that title t was
the important part that you caught out
of that right so one of the most
important gatherings for the tea
industry bianca holmen joining us live
from the convention center you've got a
look at some of the trends bianca you
said it smells fantastic and well we're
ready to taste some tea
yeah well it's not just tea that's
happening all this week we've had the
pizza expo and it's also bar and
restaurant expo all three all together
and the man that's making it all happen
i'm joined here by tim mclucas so just
tell us more about why partnering all
these groups and expos together
a great question it's really to
collaborate in the industry today i mean
we've had such success with these events
separately they're owned by different
companies we decided this year why not
do a collaboration and really make it
easier than ever before to come between
the events and share the experience the
education we have here and i know it's
more than just kind of passing out
samples and things like that even though
we've seen some great they've got white
cloud here heineken i mean i've got
everybody but also there's some
educational things as well education is
key here it's the biggest part of our
program it draws the most people here to
really support them because they need
that help how do i run my business how
do i future-proof my business for future
years after covert so education is key
runs today we had a great day yesterday
as well so it continues is very strong
but also talking about some tough topics
you know staff shortages your supply
chain issues y'all are taking on those
things as well absolutely i mean the
labor issue has been the biggest issue
we face as an industry and i think
that's the biggest hurdle we have to
overcome inflation but supply chain as
well supply chain has been crippling
some of these equipment companies and
beverage companies so a lot of topics we
have to address yeah well wonderful so
it's been great to explore out here and
again so much innovation that's
happening i know he was telling me about
tech and robotics and things like that
so again great things happening here
that of course once it happens here at
this expo then eventually we'll see it
in our restaurants and teas and online
and things like that so we're going to
send it back to you guys in the studio
yeah robots love their tea bianca